hey everybody next clips coming up in a
second but first I wanted to tell you
very briefly about one of our sponsors
Vikings war of plans it was inspired by
well-known strategy and RPG games from
the 90s like civilization which I grew
up playing and Age of Empires you're
joined by over 20 million other online
players to fight over resources create
alliances and compete in live events and
the best part is the game is totally
free and you can help support the David
Pakman show by downloading Vikings using
my link which I've put underneath this
video and when you use my link you'll
also get a special bonus of 200 gold
coins and a protective shield go check
it out
one of the sad downsides of these major
breaking stories especially ones that
break over the weekend like the four
page William Barr summary of the Moller
report is that they allow or maybe to
say a little more strongly they actually
create a really significant amount of
misinformation and disinformation they
distort they focus people in on
irrelevant or misguided lines of
reasoning and to apply that analysis to
the Trump Attorney General bar report
there has been a really specific
incorrect focus which I want to point
out today most of the reporting so far
and all of the vindication claims from
the right and even some people on the
Left have focused on the idea of
collusion but specifically on Trump
personally colluding according to bar
Muller didn't find evidence that Donald
Trump personally colluded with Russia
now on the one hand it's ridiculous to
even suspect for a moment that as a
campaign there was not any kind of
coordination or links to Russia but
again William bar has very sort of
astutely reduced it to conspiracy and
applied it specifically to the President
himself and there's clips of me a year
ago which will play for you tomorrow
saying no trust this isn't about Trump
personally plotting this stuff this is a
much more nuanced than that so that's
not surprising it's obvious all along
I've been saying
anyone who's waiting for video of Trump
and Putin planning election hijinks
together are waiting for something
they're never going to get this is about
Trump as a friend of Russia who's
impressed by Putin has laundered money
for Russians he's looked for deals in
Russia and so it's a lot of looking the
other way being friendly to Russia
letting people around him benefit from
Russia's help so yeah Moeller didn't
find Trump personally colluded no one
reasonably expected that that would be a
finding but there are two really
important things from the summary that
William Barr wrote which are not getting
attention one of them is related to
WikiLeaks the other is related to
obstruction WikiLeaks I already talked
about yesterday to very briefly remind
you deniers on the right and left were
very quick to say WikiLeaks was not at
all connected to Russian hacking
WikiLeaks had nothing to do with the
release of information hacked by
Russians from the DNC and from Hillary
Clinton but Robert Moeller
according to bars own summary says that
actually they did find that if you
accept molars other conclusions as
reported by William Bar you sort of have
to accept the conclusion that WikiLeaks
was indeed connected to Russia but most
people have remained silent on that even
people who were very actively denying
that over the course of the last year
and a half of the investigation now I
already dealt with that yesterday but
let me get to the other issue the
biggest issue right now is that Robert
Muller sort of punted the judgment on
Trump's obstruction to Trump's own
Attorney General William bar um this is
a problem for a few different reasons
number one
William Bar has previously stated he
doesn't believe a president can be
indicted for obstruction okay if you
have already said that at a systemic
level you don't think a president can be
indicted for obstruction you're not a
good arbiter of whether Donald Trump
obstructed justice and whether the
evidence indicates that Donald Trump
obstructed justice but even more
importantly bars specific bias aside for
a moment whether Trump obstructed
justice is not actually William bars
called to make and if
look at the history of this issue when a
president has obstructed justice it has
been left up to the House of
Representatives to adjudicate it not the
Attorney General who was appointed by
the President themselves remember that
robert molars report according to Barr
says Moeller was not able to exonerate
Donald Trump from obstruction of justice
when Richard Nixon was in a similar
situation the House voted for the
Judiciary Committee to investigate for
impeachment they found evidence of
obstruction they found evidence of abuse
of power and what Muller said is very
similar to what was said in the 1974
statement of John doar who investigated
Nixon that's doar now it's the house
that should be adjudicating obstruction
not Trump's own biased Attorney General
who has already said before any of the
facts were known you can't indict a
sitting president for obstruction it's
not a check-and-balance pat for the
president to select his judge which in
this case is what he is doing
by having William bar his hand-picked
attorney general get to decide what
obstruction means and if we need any
evidence that bar isn't a fair arbiter
it's that after a year and a half of
Investigation Barr was able to decide in
under 48 hours that Donald Trump doesn't
need to be charged with obstruction well
this is why we have to see the report
right I want to see what Muller had on
Trump with regards to obstruction of
justice was it just the stuff that the
public already knew about like him
firing James Comey and bullying Jeff
Sessions or does it go beyond that once
we know then maybe it is right for the
House to take up impeachment proceedings
Nancy Pelosi said before that she's
really not interested in that it may
backfire and not help Democrats come the
next election but let's get it all out
there and then we'll be able to decide
Congress will be able to decide whether
the president should be impeached for
obstruction of justice so what should
the process be bar has given us his
opinion a summary of a summary now the
House of Representatives should get the
full report and they can decide how to
proceed now Mitch McConnell has already
blocked the non-binding
resolution to get that full report to
members of the House and Senate if
there's really nothing there let it all
happen publish the report stop trying to
get Trump's written answers restricted
as has been happening let's just make it
happen let's get it out there and let's
fully exonerate Trump if you actually
believe that that's what's going to
happen what we will learn over the next
I mean it could be a few days the house
resolution that was passed which
McConnell blocked said April 2nd is when
they want the report by but that's not
happening it could be weeks could be
longer what we're going to learn is that
there is much more to the report than
Barre wants us to know okay that doesn't
mean we're gonna find evidence of Trump
colluding personally with Russia I don't
even know who was actually suggesting
that that's what we were going to get it
was an unrealistic expectation from the
beginning but there is no doubt that
bars summary of a summary simply does
not give us the full scope of what it is
that Robert Millar uncovered and
hopefully we are going to get full
access to that report at some point in
time even if it takes subpoenas from the
House of Representatives reading it out
into the Congressional Record on the
open floor of the house to eventually
get it transcribed into some kind of
format that is intelligible as the
underlying molar report make sure you're
following the david pakman show on
instagram at david pakman show and while
you're there follow me at David Pakman
we will take a quick break part two of
my interview with Natalie win of Contra
points fame is coming up next